hello everyone this is insane in the
endgame and I'm a master than in sport
so whenever you think about end games we
don't kind of expect tactical Wizards to
take over the world what they do in fact
the player we're going to talk about
today is famous for her raging attacks
and her fearsome tactical vision of
course I'm talking about
Judit Polgar that's even a get into game
one now this game was played ages ago in
1994 but already Judith had the
reputation of an active and very
aggressive player so it was kind of
natural that the soviet / russian
players tended to go for more of the
solid and game approach in fact in some
of the old books they would say okay if
you ever face a young talented opponent
just exchange the queen's make sure it's
a nice and peaceful and game and then we
end up winning the game in the long run
now to the surprise of many judith
actually really excels at end games
in fact her tactical mission helps her
to be very accurate but let's take a
look at the game that she played against
vasily smyslov
so this game was played in the women's
vs veterans which was a thing in 1994
and in this event
most of the strongest female players
were competing against older senior
grandmasters such as me Slav Geller and
etc etc c4 c5 and guess what it's the
Berlin now Judith is actually famous for
going for the main and more principled
lines so she didn't she didn't really
consider moves such as d3 which is the
height of popularity right now so she
castled
Knight takes e4 d4 Knight b6
but notice this is 1990 I mean 1994 so
we are not in the 2000s yet so it's not
yet established that the Berlin is sound
so this is pre Kasparov Kramnik match
Bishop takes c6 d takes de not f5 but
before we go head-on and deep into the
game let's first observe this position
first off white cannot really avoid the
exchange of Queens let's say if you go
clean e2 I have Knight d4 Knight takes
d4 green takes d4 and thus Queen would
be so active one one thing it would
attack the e5 pawn also after rook the
one there's this nice little trick with
Bishop g4 you don't have f3 because of
the pin and if you take I have the
bishop there and you have a loose pawn
on e5 now that means white is forced to
take on the 8th King takes the 8th so if
we observe this position one of the
things that comes to mind that what is
that if I upon doing there well for one
it actually takes away a lots of space
from black it's taking away important
squares on these 6 and f6
but what does black have that white
doesn't the bishops the bishop there is
going to be a big deal and in fact this
is typically this soviet / russian style
of play that okay i might be worse right
now we might just reach an endgame but
30 40 moves later the bishop pair will
prove its strength
so in fact judith must act energetically
to prove this space advantage is not
just a minute advantage that could just
fade away in a second so Knight c3
Bishop e6 now notice this Bishop e6 move
is
of rare you don't really see it that
often these days you either see Bishop
d7 with the idea of running with the
King to the Queen side or the main move
that is King e8 Age 3 and Age 5 and this
is the main line actually we're going to
take a look at one of her games where he
where she pays Kuryakin but Bishop e6
you can feel that this is the early
tribes in the Berlin but if you see this
move and we understand the whole concept
for black why could we pinpoint that
this Bishop e6 moves a little bit
suspicious more suspicious than going
straight into the center or trying to
hide in the Queen side
so it could potentially run to f4 f5
that's true although at the moment
there's still a knight on f5 so that's
still a problem but this actually kind
of invites white to do something and if
we already decided what is the potential
advantages of blacks position we might
notice the next move thank you
Bishop g5 and if I move my King away
mm-hmm okay so how does that attack
blacks position position from a
strategical perspective so that's kind
of the hard part of playing the Berlin
that you don't just have to win by force
you also have to play your opponent
strategically so black has the bishop
pair if we ever get the chance to get
rid of them or get rid of one of the
bishops that would be a huge achievement
for white and for Judith
mmm-hmm the problem it allows night g5
and if you move here then your Bishop is
going to be chased and harassed so if
you go see for a chat you you go here I
go b3 and then this Bishop will
eventually have to move to a6 where it
is pretty awkward
so Smith slob decides to play a King e8
now Judith didn't hesitate play rook d1
this should be seven and took on e 6f e
94 now whenever you play Knight g5 in
the Berlin there's one thing that you
really have to be conscious of and that
is the Knight d4 idea surprisingly this
C to pawn is very susceptible to being
attacked in these type of positions
let's say you play h3 which actually
wouldn't make much simpler that's just
ladyship d2 for example 94 this is one
of the ways that you could defend it
Bishop b4 and now you actually run into
these kind of tactics and black is not
even worse might even be slightly better
so you have to be really vigilant not to
miss play the Berlin endgame but Judith
is pretty vigilant so she plays rook d1
Bishop e7 Knight takes c6 f takes 694 so
in this position
Judit already established a fine knight
on e4 has the space advantage but it's
the Berlin so it'll still take some
efforts to win it
rook d8 I wonder what could be the idea
behind room d8
so obviously black has a little less
space correct so every exchange favors
the one with less space that's one of
the deals of rook d8 Smith's love wants
the exchange of Juliet's active rook
that defends this d4 square and now
Knight d4 will become a real threat
therefore she takes and place c3 and
that's kind of the mark of a super grand
master that they look for ways to
restrict any kind of play that they're
open and might have so maybe she could
play let's say King f1 and wait with c3
but then she would still give the option
of that Knight hopping in there but she
wants to make sure that Smith stuff
doesn't have any counter play from the
get-go that's the sign of a good player
c3 also c3 prepares an idea what could
that be
if you think about it some of the black
pieces are a little awkward
yep g4 could become a real threat not
yet and it's very committal
so whenever white will play g4 she will
be certain that it's good but it does
look tempting doesn't it because this
night only has one decent square and
that's on h4 so that's kind of lingering
in the air let's continue h6 h3 so she
actually prepares potential ideas of g4
but she's not rushing with it she so
she's actually just hinting at it that
okay I might play it in the future
you'll think about it and in the right
moment I just gotta do it
King c8 preparing to bring the rook into
the game we got faith King e29 h4 and
black is basically trying to provoke
some weaknesses but Judith tries to be
conservative g3 if Knight g6 I have f4
ideas but I don't necessarily have to
play f4 but if you I want to stabilize
this a very good idea Knight f3 how can
we defend against this very aggressive
idea of course Bishop f4 and suddenly
this Knight has to go because this
Bishop is just blocking the view the
rook Knight h4 and here Judah comes up
with a very exciting plan now note if
there would be no light pieces and rooks
on the board what would be the result of
the game
so if you would just get all of our
pieces of the board
what would be the result of the opponent
game there yeah white would be on the
word you're winning because we have an
extra pawn on the Kings side and should
be just a clear win therefore any chance
we get to exchange heavy or light pieces
we'll take it
so Judah is going to go for that note we
can never take that night because our
Bishop is hanging and if we would take
on h6 then black would capture back and
then that ePHI pawn becomes extremely
weak so in fact that bishop on f4 is
fairly useful so we have to be very
specific in ways we might want to use it
so whenever I look at this type of
position first of all I look hmm is my
opponent's king weak not really but then
where can I find a target and that's a
big question if I can find a target in
blacks position it's much easier to come
up with a constructive plan so she
played Bishop III Nagi sit Knight f3 I
mean I g6 the same thing she could go f4
or play the move that she played here so
if we notice that this c6 pawn is the
culprit and we need to get rid of it how
can we get close to that pawn Knight c5
but then probably I could take em go
over cap 7 and then you still have to
deal with this Knight
so a bishop is a good defender but the
Knights are great attackers especially
in these Berlin structures as you shall
see in the upcoming game that I'm going
to show you guys
so she played Bishop c5 as she no longer
decides to defend at e5 pawn she decides
to exchange this defender for another
defender so she can attack with the
knight with the remaining knight and
this will be the killer beasts of the
game Knight takes e5 and I take c6 and
this is again precisely calculated by
Judith as there's no rooky 8 here as
that would run into knight XG 7 here
takes again you'd hope that you would
get some checks in but uh uh I have
another attack on the rook and then I
can swiftly hide with my king so
everything is working perfectly so far
for Judah rook g8 was played Smith's
love is conservative and plans to
innovate with the King rook e1 bringing
in the rook now this rook e1 move looks
a little strange but what could be the
underlying idea that Judit might have
with this move
in fact rookie one is anticipating
something yeah exactly
so she's anticipating black to tag the
night but then she has a very nice
little tactical idea in mind F for King
D 7 b3 stopping any jumps and after King
takes c6 King f2 and again who said that
tactics don't matter in end games and
that was kind of big foresight from
Judith because at first look Ricky one
looks strange right it doesn't look like
the most natural move you might consider
rook d1 let's say here but then that
could run into tricks like night c4
hitting the pawn and when you would push
b3 I could go Rocky eight leading to
roughly even endgame one could even get
worse because sometimes these pawns do
get weak but rook e1 kind of anticipates
that the action is mostly going to be on
the e-file and nowhere else b6 f 4 and
b3 in fact b3 is also a very nice little
move not varying that much about the
night and would only move the knight
whenever the e5 Pony retreats King takes
e6 King f2 rook the 8th takes King up 6
kingi - alright so the first part of the
endgame is done how would we summarize
what happened here is why better is
white winning
I mean obviously white achieved
tremendous advantage compared from the
beginning compared to the beginning of
the game but it has an extra pawn on the
kingside and bike did not manage to come
up with any plans on the queenside
as of yet what else what else
give give us some hope for white so we
have a better pawn structure you have an
extra pawn on the Kings side but what
else do we have that black doesn't
really have
the rook is stronger it's in the center
way more active also we took away all
the entry squares from this rook but
what can we say about the Kings which
King is better the Viking is much less
restricted yes and this King is
basically stuck on the Kings side so
Smith's love is forced to come up with
plans with only the rook but as we know
in n games the strongest piece is
clearly the King rook d5 do we want to
help our opponent to get a better
structure now next time rook e8 and now
Smith's love comes up with an
interesting idea just a black to move
and come up with an interesting plan try
to look for a counter play
so definitely we should be seeking play
on the queenside if flag doesn't get
enough counter play there eventually
this end game should be one for Judit so
it's time to go rock a5 a4 b5 and
probably at this moment Smith's love was
content with whatever happened but it's
Judah to move and consolidate and she'll
get a hefty advantage after this move
white to move and play
mm-hmm Ruki 5 and that's kind of a move
that is easy to miss you kind of expect
Judith to go and go hunt for pawns with
rook e8 c8 but suddenly the rook returns
and you cannot move your rook anymore
and if you just wait I'll just walk up
with my king and say bye-bye to your
rook couldn't even go d4 c5 maybe later
but the long plan is just as good in
fact that's better because you don't
want to get checked
so Smith Slav panicked and played rook a
6-8 XB v bouquet three rook c5 now this
is the technical part and Judah actually
as she's naturally a tactical player she
looks for concrete solutions and that's
very important and that might sound
surprising but in fact in end games one
of the most important thing is is to be
accurate and if you're a good calculator
that does count in in the end of the
game so C takes b5 rook takes b5 a5 now
we're up upon we're happy for that but
the question is how to convert and just
a little bit of a hint we can't really
win three against two on the same side
so we need to come up with a
constructive plan here to actually
convert this winning and game
so if we look at the Queen side does
anyone have an advantage on the Queen
side at the moment
not really it's a balanced fight right
there but we want to make it uneven you
want to win this battle on the Queen
side so we should go king d3 because as
long as we bring our king in these pawns
will become protected and we can go
ahead hunt for pawns on c7 and 85 King
e6 King c4 so now Smith slope starts
rushing himself but he's too late this
King was much faster and now Judith does
the business King c4 a4 b4 so she's not
looking for exchanges she's confident
that she can stop this a pawn while she
might have plans of pushing her pawns on
the Queen side as well okay to row k5
whenever you plan to go a3 the king will
have enough time to go back and take
that pawn they three actually that
happens King b3 rook h2 rook takes a 3G
for rock III at five and okay five six
and rook g6
and suddenly the King got trapped
you can't really go back because there's
real things jeez I mean you can't go
back it's not room Teague's g7 if you
don't go back there I'll take on g7 but
if you go here its mate so what Judith
did in the sand game was first of
consolidate your advantage make sure you
exchange off all those light pieces get
the extra pawn on the Kings side and
then activate your King and because of
plenty of inaccuracies and the end of
Smith's by Smith's love he actually went
down fairly quickly especially because
rookie 7 would run into c4 checkmate so
this was her early games in the Berlin
but before we look at her more prominent
game against Kuryakin which was in 2011
let's look at some games where she
actually uses some tactics to outsmart
her opponents
so this was an IED Orff
night or in fact smash neck of that is
excuse me queen b7 and seemingly black
is going to have enough pressure on the
d5 pawn you can't really go rook t1
because the B to pawn is falling so
Judith decides to play Knight a3 she
decides to give a give the pawn back
Queen takes d5 takes takes Knight c4 and
at the moment she's attacking two pawns
but and the world comes up with this
interesting idea rook b8 and now it's
Judith to move and take advantage of the
situation so we just entered the endgame
we joined the fight on move 22 at the
moment it does seem that Edouard has a
control of the situation but you'll see
how Judith outsmart him in the long run
so as you can see this is an endgame but
there's a lot of tactics going on this
rook on b1 is fairly undefended and
there's some Knight takes c3 tricks here
which could get really annoying so
Judith will have to figure out a way to
get out of trouble or at least move out
of that trick
so if you look at the pawn structure who
has a better pawn structure why
definitely has a more intact structure
black has many many pawn islands
actually three and on the contrary Judit
only has two which is a positive that
means if Judith manages to reorganize
her pieces she will get the advantage
but for that we need to come up with
moves which is defensive in nature but
actually will stabilize the situation
for white so the next move is a very
nice stabilizing move
rook d1 if you go rook d1 the issue is I
can go Knight b6 hitting your rook and
Knight we exchange and suddenly the beet
soup on his weak again and that is kind
of the big dilemma how can we defend
against Knight takes c3 without
beginning the b2 pond yeah we can play
only one of them both seem good
well according to the rules of chess you
have to choose one
so yeah in a row k1 root and rook a1 or
ruk a3 does look very tempting I agree
what does your intuition tell you ok 3
mm-hmm now probably ruk a3 could also
work but what Judah played was a rook a
a 1
the point being she wants to be a
hundred percent sure that the b1 rook is
protected and there is no funny business
with Knight c3 and rook be one as it
would happen here and this wouldn't even
that be that funny as he would lose
everything you wouldn't want that
so rook a a1 and suddenly all of those
pawns are really hanging so black plays
a four we are not going to fall for this
cheapo of taking that pawn the knight c3
that would be sad so we play Bishop f3
Knight b6 takes takes rook takes a 4
rook c8 so black does have some pressure
here on these fonts but we are up upon
now
in opposite colored bishop positions /
and games what could be a potential
target
notice that this Bishop is a pretty bad
defender compared if I attack on white
squares that is this Bishop is kind of
useless so we might want to go for an
attack
Bishop d5 and that is exactly what unit
is preparing she is preparing an attack
on the f7 square now note that rook
takes c3 would fail miserably as we
would just give a check gobble
everything and checkmate on the 8th
Bishop d2 édouard is trying to stabilize
on the black squares so if we will play
C 4 then the bishop would be maneuver
itself to c5 and probably could dream of
holding c4 row B 8
I mean the main issue is still root K 7
and the weakness on that f7 square Ruby
8 ro k 7 g 6 rook takes f7 King h8 now
if we think about this what will be the
next few moves for black
black is at the moment down to pons
that's no good you have to win long palm
back so probably black is going to take
on b2 and that means that white has one
or two extra moves to make so we got to
make it good
so once the rooks are exchanged on b2 do
they have any mating ideas by any chance
well then the plan would be is to build
the mating net around the black King so
I'll tell you a little secret it's not
gonna work with just the rook and the
bishop you need some reinforcements
hmmm well that's an idea but I can still
exchange you on b1 right and your g3
move is a little bit too conservative
I'm not sure it helps you in mating the
black King so you have to find a little
bit more aggressive more inspired move
and actually Judith's move is pretty
nice
she played h4 rook takes me to take
stakes and what mating concept was Judah
coming up here why did she play h4
exactly to set up this mating idea of g4
g5 and checkmate on g8 and you might
think that end games are dry and boring
but sometimes you can check me people
there as well
g4x clam g5 is coming
rogue g8 g5 and suddenly black is doomed
to wait and if he doesn't then he'll run
into trouble as we shall see rogue d8
kingi - now White has many plans but one
of them is to walk the King up and play
h5 and then have the target on h7 h6
so therefore add to our panic a little
bit and played h6 himself but this runs
into a beautiful idea
white to move and play
h5 indeed you can really take this way
because H takes and rotate 7 and G G and
if you take this way well it's the same
thing different design you're still
gonna get made in late 7 with a double
pawn on the H file so blacks only hope
is rook g8 but Judith calculated far
enough and she's going to conclude in
two more moves let's try to find those
moves
as you can see this rook is kind of
stuck there
so if we could force some actions and
break through on this g6 square we might
win the game also note that this Bishop
has some influence on that g8 rook you
might want to use that idea
rook up six and if I take the pawn on g5
yeah that would run into that one and
eventually black will get a little bit
of a chance to hold their
so why played rook d7 the idea being we
want this rook to get misplaced and get
into a bad bad situation know that it
cannot really run away because we're
just taken is the same checkmate so
black is forced to play room g7 but this
one is losing
after Judith's next move
Edward resigned
mmm-hmm Bishop f7 and there's no defense
left
probably Bishop g5 is the best but it
just doesn't help because I'm going to
take that pawn and promote and just win
and if you take any other way I'll take
on g6 and rook d8 is just mating so this
is a very pretty finish by judith
alright so this is one of those n games
that I wanted to show but she had
another fantastic opposed to the colored
bishop and game that I want to show so
this was played in Ningbo the world
teams championship where judith was
facing the israeli Yevgeniy posny posny
seemingly equalized here we have the
same amount of pieces and black
management manages to change Queen's
Bishop g7 and it seems that black is a
move away from equalizing but Judah
comes up with a very nice little twist
and she will get the initiative
so it's wait to move and get the
initiative
so definitely we want to take the pawn
because what else Bishop takes e5 and
here comes the big question there's a
lot of things going on here we could
take on b7 we could take on e5
does any of that give us an advantage
probably not because if we take here
rook takes Bishop takes takes takes and
we end up in an equal rockin game but
not much hope for anyone to win can we
take on b7 we could but then Bishop
takes f4 and it's an opposite colored
ending with not much hope there as this
Bishop does this black colored Bishop
would be extremely strong but what if we
could get post nice black squared bishop
wouldn't that be ideal ah-huh bishop c6
and this is a nifty little idea you
can't really take there because I win an
exchange and that's good news for white
so black is basically forced to take on
c6 rook takes e5 and we've got the black
squared bishop and look at all those
holes in blacks position that is
advantage white so let's take a look how
judith is going to win this endgame rook
takes e5 Bishop takes e5 rook c8 and the
next move is very important
without that probably it would likely
would end in a draw let's try to find
the next move if you find it probably we
would win this game as well just as
Judah did
g4 what's the idea behind g4 so if I
understand your concept what if I play
f5 and try to escape try to escape with
knocking
no I mean g4 is a very interesting idea
but you might need to be a little bit
more precise
exactly and that's what she played and
now this King on g8 is pronounced dead
it's kind of waiting for whites to do
something but bite itself this King
cannot really run away and whenever this
rook plans to get active
we just remind them of the potential
checkmating ideas now if you would ask
me if this positions winning for white
I'd say no it's not winning but great
meaning chances as black is doomed to
defend passively now a computer might
defend it maybe but in a practical game
this is very tough so let's see how Jude
and managed to win this one King f8 now
comes your move g4 with the idea of g5
just making sure that Bishop stays there
when I have sex
rook e8 King h2 climbing up rook e6
check just a warning check remaining
posny that you know if you go too far
I'm gonna checkmate you rook e8 rook d1
rookie six g5 now you might ask me why
did they repeat a move well it's move 32
and these and in these open tournaments
/ team events you get extra move at move
40 so you might want to make some extra
moves so you can reach the 40 quicker
route d6
are we excited about the idea of
exchanging Brooks not this time
rook a 1 so where is this rook headed to
which Square
a seven we're trying to infiltrate on
the dark squares rug d2r okay seven not
worrying about that f2 pawn if you would
take go here rook somewhere here rook to
xe7 you must stay here on e8 which is
very awkward if you go Bishop d5 you
have to contend with potential tricks
because if I check rook e8 you still
have one square but it's getting really
scary right now also I can just go c4
and create a passed pawn and probably
personally wanted to avoid this so what
okay actually it took okay it's not bad
rookie - Brooke - xe6 he actually played
rookie six and we reaching this end game
and Judith manages to get the C pawn
active h4 rook b8 just making sure that
there is no funny business on the B file
rookie one c4 takes takes now the big
question is how can we proceed can we
win this any game with without the help
of this King on f3
not really we need the help of the King
and that's something to remember from
these end games you always the need that
need the help of the king rookie 6c 5
rook c6 Bishop e5 and again tactics
you can't take this Bishop d6 check
rookie 6 Guinea for so in fact Bishop e5
is more of like a defensive idea as
Judah is just built using it as a bridge
she's crossing using the bishop on the
e5
King g5 and this king is coming to d5 in
d7 check King d4 now obviously King d5
would be a terrible mistake because of
Bishop c6 losing the rook King V for
Bishop d7 r okay seven in fact preparing
a future invasion of king d5 King c8 but
to be honest that's not that easy to
achieve as you will have to prepare it
with some sort of Bishop d6 and King d5
as if you go King D 5 now there's always
a check on c6 so Bishop d6 was played
King the 8th check
and King d5 rookie two and now the
question is how should we proceed here
they're very close to winning it's not
winning yet because anytime you come
close to the black King there's a rookie
six move which holds for the moment my
big question is should we push the pawn
or should we try to kind of put black
into it suits wrong position
mmm-hmm why put back in it so long why
not just try to win with c6 indeed c6
would be extremely committal and would
take away this very nice square from the
white king also even though the computer
would say c6 is the best winning
whatever King c6 is the human move that
makes sure that okay I'm going to slowly
press you and see how it goes from there
if you go see sex if it's bad you could
just rotate the advantage so I assume
that Judit Polgar decided to play king
c6
on these terms that she's sure that she
has the advantage and she doesn't feel
the need to commit with c6 just yet king
c6 and also Bishop c7 is a big threat
planning to win that Bishop rook e6 or
okay 7 plants it's wrong putting
pressure on that pawn also this Bishop
is basically stalemated you can't make
any moves on any of these squares have
six GF rook f6 you're still pinned so no
such thing as Bishop e7 rotate seven and
this is typical typical prophylaxis
she's anticipating g5 ideas and trying
to create counter play she made make
sure that she has her rook behind this
potential passer rookie six rook g7 as
the rock moves she attacks the g6 pawn
bishop a6
King died five rookie two and now she
decides it's time she in fact activated
her rook from a8 brought it to the
seventh rank and she felt that combining
the mating threats she she is just ready
to push the pawn king he ate
rokay seven bishops e8r okay eight and
now she goes back forcing the King back
to defend from the eighth Bishop f4 and
comes the big plan of smothering the
King on the eighth rookie one King d6
king c5 now black was forced to give
this check otherwise both c7 rook takes
c8 or Bishop g5 would win the Bishop
rook the 8th King c5 rugby won and now
comes the winner move white to move and
clinch the game it's a subtle little
move that means on the spot
so our goal is is to separate this needy
King that is just so attached to that
Bishop on c8 if we could do that it's
game over now if you keep checking that
doesn't do much if you play c7 black
would be extremely happy because the
king would be on white squares finally
but on d8 is actually a potential target
so if you can succeed the checks on the
kingside where else could you look for
the solution
yeah
/ okay 7r o k7 we haven't looked at it
yet
but it doesn't really help us in the
goal of taking the c8 bishop
so why played the subtle yeah I heard a
suggestion go ahead if you go Bishop g5
I move my king to c7 yes exactly
Bishop d2 and the point is if you can't
really win the game on the kingside you
can try from the other side and because
there's no rook c1 here because we just
take it black resigned as king c7
actually would run into this unreal but
beautiful checkmate on b6 so this was
the two opposite colored bishop and
games I wanted to show from Judit Polgar
but last and not least I want to show
her game that she want against Sergei
Kuryakin in fact this was one of her
best World Cups
in 2011 where she defeated both Lenny
Dominguez Kuryakin and most ASEAN over
media and eventually she succumbed to
sweater the eventual winner but this is
the wind that actually qualified Judith
to the next round
so e4 e5 and again they're trying to
lure dudn't into the endgame but that
proves to be a fatal mistake takes takes
and this time we seen earlier the Bishop
e6 line but that was in 1994 so they
play King he ate that's the main line
now H 3 H 5 Rob d1 as we talked about it
before the point of rook d1 is a to
occupy the open file B to control the d4
square there should be seven and as we
talked about this earlier in the Berlin
endgame it's very important for right to
stay energetic once white loses steel
and speed in her play den des the moment
when black often takes over
now g4 would be crazy because H takes H
stakes at night h4 and that Bishop is
just ready to pounce on that pawn on
this square but if we want to activate
our pieces how would we do that in this
position if we follow the age-old
principles of chess
so we already have a lot of space that
means we have lots of room to move
around with our pieces and if we have a
lot of legroom you want to use it right
we wouldn't want that to go to waste
so here Judith played 94 just taking
that good old central square which was
just right there to grab Bishop d7 and
as we talked earlier and I keep
repeating it black does have the bishop
pair and probably Judith and no white
player is too happy about that fact so
if we know that can we guess her next
move
so Judith spotted that his Bishop on e7
is a good old target so she played
Bishop g5 and planted to get rid of that
Bishop now she's not forcing that yet
but she wouldn't object either if Bishop
takes g5 nine things g5 would happen
white would be content also note that
sometimes there are little tactics right
there even in the endgame if let's say
if okay try boom you take I'll take your
Bishop and again I would gobble up all
the Queen side pawns and be happy but
obviously Kuryakin
excuse me is a good old classical player
it doesn't fall for tricks plays rook d
8c for grabbing some space also taking
away this juicy d5 spot from the bishop
b6 and now it's not as easy as it might
look to come up with a plan for a white
and as I learned recently when in doubt
double your rooks
so she's actually just planning to
solidly double the rooks bishops e8 rook
takes d8 king things d8 check and
probably Kuryakin is somewhat content as
he got rid of this passive rook on a8
but why could be also content because
she has an active rook on the d5 but
this while this rook on h8 is kind of
awful so here as he's seen you know the
e7 and g5 bishops are flirting with each
other the question is will anything
really happened
probably not because if we see these
fonts they're all on the dark squares so
Judith decides to refrain from
exchanging c-5 and here comes Judith's
idea why to move and play and probably
this Bishop f4 surprised kurakin
probably he was expecting some exchanges
on e7 which would have eased the tension
but Judith was going for more
so notice that this King on eh has
already moved more than once so castling
is no option that will mean that this
King will have to waste additional time
to get activated
so if Judah could muster up an attack in
this position that would probably very
difficult to withstand or withhold so
here if we could strike in due time but
would get an advantage
and in its ecigs activate your bishops
at all costs
sometimes even why gives up the pawn
just to activate her pieces now this
bishop will be extremely powerful as all
of these phones are on black squares
that's why you're trying to put your
pawns on the opposite color of the
bishop that your opponent has so Bishop
takes c6 Bishop takes e7 and again as I
talked before this King has already
moved so it'll take some additional time
to activate itself so f6 is played but
this runs into a very thematic way of
winning a pond that's Bishop b8 and the
bishop is just gonna fish for pawns a6
Bishop e7 Bishop d8 and probably
karyakin was content here as this pawn
is well defended by the bishop
you can't enter through the d6 square 96
takes doesn't really work if you go here
I take you here King he's 7 and the King
d7 would even trap the rook so wide had
to change his plans yes rook things they
definitely could be considered and
probably knowing Judith she considered
it and would get two pawns and a piece
probably good compensation for white but
it's a little bit double-edged black
does get rook for those pieces now I
think Judith realized that okay I don't
have to sacrifice I can just go and play
Knight c3 plan is to go Knight c3 Knight
a4 and suddenly you don't have enough
defenders also this bishop is overloaded
if this bishop would go to d7 stopping
then the d5 square would be vacant for
this night and now it's over
because
gonna take the pawn and it's game over
so hurry up gameplay is king f7 but
there's not a 4 B 5 Knight takes e5
Bishop c8 and again here it comes the
technical phase
Judah is up a pawn but black still has
some counter play so obviously our
advantage is on the Queen side what
should we do if we have the advantage on
the Queen side
well let's look for some exchanges we're
up upon so we're happy to exchange them
see takes it takes a four she's looking
to create a passer on the a file ba ba
Ruki eight rugby one now again this is
the sign of an elite player they're
making sure that there's minimum risk to
mess up and also to get rid of blacks
counterplay she's looking forward to
exchange off the bishop and then black
wouldn't have even the bishop pair for
the pawn as a compensation g5 Bishop b6
Bishop e7 so naturally Kuryakin tries to
keep the bishop pair on the board
a5 and here
Kuryakin had a decision to make could
try to wait but the spawn is menacingly
close to turn into a lady so he decided
to take on c5 Bishop takes e5 and the
point of this exchange is that in the
future maybe he could dream of building
a fortress as it's an it could lead to
an opposed to the colored bishop endgame
if Judith were to miss lay it a little
bit rookie six will be six now it
changes are still really good for Judith
as Knights are still on the board so
this is by no means a clear opposite
colored Bishop and game now g7 Bishop
III and I really like this move Bishop
III she's making sure that there's no
rookie invasions not only to not only
one not in the future Bishop III Knight
a5 rugby eight and these are these
little subtle moves that make for a good
technique she's not moving her bishop
yet she forces this Bishop to concede
are you going to do seven are you going
to a six show your hands
rook e8 so neither okay eight so then
she makes sure that she can start
pushing the pump if that pawn reaches
the seventh rank it's probably going to
be game over we should be 7r okay seven
and even though this rook looks a little
bit miserable it's a good helper for
this a pawn rook e7 Bishop c5 a6 Bishop
c6 now the rooks are exchanged but again
white achieved a lot the pawn is already
on a6 and the only thing is left is to
activate this night now if you're
wanting to promote that Asics pawn where
would we like to transport our Knights
or our knight on f3
b6 so our route probably is going to be
92 94 and I b6 and here she comes King
e6 night C for problem is for karaoke
and the King bee if I've naturally would
win a piece but here it would run into a
Czech takes Knight takes D 7 and not
only I'm gonna promote I'm gonna gobble
up all your pawns
so Bishop c6 was played 90 b6 and
naturally there's no way the King can
come any closer because all these
squares are taken away and a7 is coming
96 Bishop takes d6 King takes a 7 King
c7 and this is a funny idea by Kuryakin
he actually traps Judith's night but is
this enough no it's not because f4 is
coming and Kuryakin resigned because
even though he picks up the night the
king will walk up and pick up all the
pieces right there
so just take stakes and the King just
walks up and collects all of the pawns
and collects the game and this was
Judith's big win against Sergey Karjakin
the Challenger who faced Carlsen and I
really hope you enjoyed Judit Polgar
famous and exciting insane and games
thank you so much for watching
you
[Music]
you